how in your opinion how would you tell
our men to men up man up now and our
women to be more feminine
um as a society
i would tell men to um
be stronger in their leadership um
that's abuse
like that that's what i'm saying like if
they told you that's abusive what would
you say because men try to get back into
the leadership role but they end up
being abusive and they get canceled or
what like i don't i don't understand
that about like how so if you were a guy
how would you
let's let's role-play
okay so
role-play time go ahead yeah okay so if
if a guy was being a weak [ __ ] okay
that you're gonna be a weak [ __ ] but
now how would you get more masculine
just what would you do
so i'm not debating with you i just
think make more money thanks how would
you make more money you would say just
make more money that's how they would
get more masculine i think so like
do something in leadership and make
money like i really feel like that's
really it yeah and like don't let people
walk all over you i don't know what
better way to put that like be assertive
have something to show for yourself be a
leader
and make an income like man up is what
you're saying yeah i feel like that's
what that's what men do justin go ahead
weigh in on this topic
here where you went on this on
where do you want to start go how do you
tell women to be more feminine without
them getting offended if you're actually
acting the way you're supposed to you
won't have to you can take the same
woman if a man walks up to you man a
you actually like him and man b walks up
to you and you don't like him you're
going to respond completely different
one of those guys are going to be creepy
one of them's going to be charming
so
in regard in regards to how a man should
act with a woman if if a man is acting
how a man should act yeah then the woman
is not going to have a problem getting
into that role
women respect men they love period the
end so if you can't respect me you can't
love me yeah
i agree
[Music]